okay so here's a little behind the
scenes what you may not see the biggest
thing everyone always complains about is
they're hungry during the Oscars that's
a long day it is a very long day Adam
Shapiro and Katie Lowe's are here with a
solution yes we are oh yeah
[Applause]
two and a half years ago during the
pandemic one of my favorite regular
customers is Jimmy Kimmel he called me a
couple weeks ago and he's like we need
to put a Shabby pencil under every seat
at the Oscars and I was like the bakery
since one o'clock in the morning making
four thousand four thousand pretzels or
the Oscars and they were left yet and
they were like what's that gonna cost us
I said uh I just want to go with my wife
and be on the red carpet at the Oscars
and here we are and here we are the fact
that you started this during the
pandemic what made you in whatever mind
you had to say I'm gonna start a
business during the pandemic and a
pretzel business honestly I never would
have thought to start a business or a
personal business but I'm from Philly
and the one thing we love in Philly is
our Philly soft pretzels and Katie like
host Ryan and Kelly whenever Kelly goes
on vacation and we
and my house
good time and Seacrest was like what's
Adam been up to I'm like he's perfecting
the art of making the Philly Soft
Pretzel and I was like yo Seacrest I'm
bringing you some tomorrow which he did
and then he ate them on air and it's
been two and a half years where we do
like weddings cast visit I mean we do
weddings funerals
it's a whole thing I can smell them by
the way I can smell them right now and
they're in the bathroom tell Jimmy next
year because we did 4 000 for everybody
sat inside but we need to have given all
of these people we needed to do five
thousand like what's going on yeah we
get hungry out here too in the media
okay so shopypretzel.com but we're here
for the snacks we're here for the snacks
baby make a pretzel really speak I mean
everyone's been working so hard to fit
to their dresses and their underpinnings
and all that and then the show's gonna
start and they're going to get to have
this delicious salty carbohydrate that
puts down a nice layer before the After
parties so it's really the perfect snack
I'm really rooting for Top Gun tonight
you are yeah I love TOMCO I was about to
ask you you know what my baby cousin
who's no longer a baby now that he's 30
years old Louis Pullman was would play
Bob in Top Gun and knowing this one yeah
yeah and he's gonna be here tonight and
I can't wait to see him yes yes
absolutely okay we're very excited we're
very excited it's our first time at the
Oscars and it's all thanks to pretzels
show your cufflinks oh yeah that's just
a little no you don't have a pretzel
cufflink that's a pretzel cufflink right
there this man I love this man okay so
the good there you go
yeah we gotta do it big for tonight
you've got work to do okay but every
under every seat during the Academy
Awards there will be a shopping spread
that's exactly right love that okay
y'all have a good time
have a good night thank you guys thanks
Katie
[Music]
thank you